here to comment is the devil i mean you
take that back right now you take it
back colin okay or i swear i will go
back on our deal to let you marry
scarlet okay
jason sudeikis was hell-bent on bringing
the laughs on saturday night live i have
a tendency to ramble
well consider us grateful for that
because jason's snl hosting debut did
not disappoint here to comment is the
devil
during weekend update the emmy winner
reprised his friendly take on the man in
red i'm also into sports oh you know
yeah yeah i've been sticking my fork in
sports uh you know i i mean you saw that
the astros won yeah they should now
jason left the series as a full-time
cast member in 2013 and there was a lot
of catching up to do with the character
and uh you know my boy tom brady's still
going strong
i actually keep his soul trapped in this
portrait of him
and before wrapping up the segment we
got this hilarious exchange from colin's
personal life i mean you take that back
right now you take it back colin okay or
i swear i will go back on our deal to
let you marry scarlet okay
[Applause]
that's not what happened you baby
trapped
[Applause]
actually jason revisited quite a few of
his memorable characters on saturday
trick or treat smell my feet and i'm
just joking
the actor broke out the aviators again
to play our now president in the night's
opening sketch the ghost the biden pass
boom
the dual bidens showcased just how much
the world has changed since his veep
days
you seem so happy sound
carefree
so so uh what's the word i'm looking for
luther
he also threw on the tracksuit for
keenan thompson's fan favorite sketch
that asked the question
[Music]
[Applause]
but we saw there's only so much running
man the body can take bass man it's good
to see you how those knees doing
when it came to the monologue jason took
a page out of ted lasso's playbook with
a sincere and heartfelt tribute to 30
rock uh all kidding aside it's uh it's
really special to be back in studio 8h
this room here here i mean think about
all the brilliance that's happened in
here
all your favorite sketches wild and
crazy guys gilly cowbell wayne's world
and then over here you've got i mean
this is where all the music happened
right
all that music elvis costello kanye
nirvana the rolling stones while he was
feeling sentimental jason also took a
moment to share what snl has meant to
him over the years this place changed my
life twice twice once as a cast member
as a writer here
but most importantly as a kid watching
from home
jason chatted with e.t last week and
shared his excitement about the hosting
gig i don't know if working there for 10
years is going to be a plus or a minus
we won't know but yeah i'm looking
forward to the even just the tuesdays
and wednesdays the writing and the read
through you know saturday i always i've
known for for years that it feels like
being shut out of a rocket ship and
people are like it's already done so i'm
gonna i'm gonna savor the parts of the
week that i enjoyed when working so
right because you're a vet are you gonna
write two this week and you're gonna
like you're gonna jump and do everything
well i mean they have so many you know
folks there right now between cast and
writing that i know when i work there
that always bum me out when someone else
would write or bring guests and stuff
i'd be like
get out of here paul mccartney we don't
need you
like you know
get out of here steve martin